you need a mic but you need something
that won't leave your broke for the next
two weeks but wait you also need an
audio interface to plug in an extra mic
so you can get your friends on that
podcast you plan on for the last two
years but it can't leave you broke for
another month well do I have news for
you the amount of Costa AME 2 podcasting
console and the monodynamic pd200x
microphone come cheaper in a bundle at
the time of recording at us 179.99 or SG
247 the car still works like or rather
it is an auto interface you can hook up
two microphones into it one with XLR and
the other via a 3.5 millimeter Jack and
it comes with a bunch of stuff like a
launch pad that can record audio from
your phone like I've done with this Euro
dance meme
[Music]
you've got effects here denoise and even
auto-tune in 12 Keys which in the right
hands can entertain the masses the right
hands being me no no
I can feel something inside me say I
really don't think the amount of dynamic
PD 200x is the second cheapest
microphone in mounters lineup the first
being the pd100 at 49.99 USD and this
pd200x comes in at 79.99 USD what is
great about this microphone aside from
its budget pricing is that it also has
the option of using XLR or a USBC plus a
3.5 millimeter for monitoring if you're
planning to use the mic alone and we're
going to be switching over from our road
Wireless go to microphone that I'm using
right now through this once I'm done
telling you what's inside these boxes
the ame2 podcasting console comes with a
usb-c usba cable two 3.5 millimeter
cables and the console with the
instructions documentations and all that
jazz the pd200x dynamic microphone comes
with a USBC USBC cable with a USB 8
adapter attached to it an XLR cable and
the microphone with the stand alright
time to switch it up so if you want the
microphone you have RGB which it has RGB
you need to like plug it in at the same
time right one two three one two three
okay so this is how the dynamic PDF 200x
sounds like while running through the
amount of cost ame2 podcasting console
the Reverb has been turned off and so
has a denoise and I'm going to turn the
denoise back on
and yeah even with low noise
cancellation it sounds pretty alright
let's start off with the microphone how
you position the microphone obviously
makes a big difference because this
Dynamic mic is in a cardioid polar
pattern you get better audio when you
aim the top directly in your mouth hole
like so so we're going to start off with
the microphone facing me directly and
I'm going to be shifting it over to my
right and now you're going to be hearing
more of such a typing to me and shifting
it to my left
you're going to be hearing nothing no
back to me stop puts nothing much below
yep and back to me and then there is a
swivel on this thing here as well so I
just need to loosen it up
turn it towards you and lock it in place
now if you prefer to have this mounted
with an arm mono does provide a shock
mount to protect the microphone from
vibrations that travel from the boom or
mic stand to the microphone so let's
test that real quick and
all right not much
[Music]
you don't really hear much of the stand
vibrating
now hitting the stand itself the stem
nothing much and now the microphone
all right sick
okay so what I picked up in the comment
section and I do read the comments by
the way I'm going to be aiming the
microphone to the 12th fret of the
guitar and this is how I get better
sound so
[Music]
okay so now that we have the arm on
let's do the shock mount test real quick
picking up a little bit
obviously that's a bit more tremendous
but
hitting the stem
all right
[Music]
then
that
foreign
Ty isn't terrible it isn't
overwhelmingly fantastic but it's a good
start you know it doesn't sound like
you're recording through a trash can and
somewhat emulates some of the
microphones out there we've got a few so
let me give you all a quick comparison
and no not all of them have stands and
boom arms so it is what it is but you'll
get a better idea of what you're getting
into so we've got the amount of pd200x
up against decent Heiser profile
microphone the Razer 7 V2 Pro and the
Blue Yeti and just for fun things I'm
also going to throw in this Lenovo
Legion H300 headset that costs about us
30 dollars this is how the Razer 7 V2
Pro Sounds like I'm running this
directly into our MSI laptop off screen
and this is how it sounds like this is
how the Blue Yeti X sounds like I'm
running this directly into the MSI
laptop we have off screen and this is
how the Blue Yeti X sounds like this is
decent Heiser profile USB microphone I'm
running this directly into the mslr that
we have over there and this is how the
synthesizer profile USB microphone
sounds like let's do a quick test let's
see how this arm handles banging
foreign
[Music]
not much compared to the mono
unfortunately
this the Lenovo Legion hits 200 headset
with the on-bought microphone it's
connected into the MSI laptops 2.5
auxiliary port over there or the
headphone jack and this is how it sounds
like let me know which of the
microphones you like the most in the
comment section below and before we
continue this channel is supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stay around for
this sponsored message meet the Cyber 15
gaming laptop from MSI check out this
translucent material design that only
looks good but feels good thanks to its
Ultra lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12 gen
Intel Core i7 H series processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immersed with its nahimic twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com I have moved back to
the stand because I prefer this over the
microphone arm that we got so we'll be
keeping this for the rest of the video
this microphone obviously has RGB be in
a spectrum mode and several static
colors you can mute the mic adjust the
gain and hit the volume with the knobs
here and here and again this is a plug
and play USBC microphone with a USBC
cable if you omit the XLR put these
solid stuff at its individual price
there's really no BS with this product
it's solid but now let's shift over to
the podcasting console let's go to the
console there are sliders for microphone
volumes on here as I am chasing up and
down you can hear that and then there's
this phantom power which is for the
evolved you can press this but it kind
of cuts out the microphone for a bit as
you can hear right
here I know the owners come to the
nikons and now we are back to the
microphone so keep that in mind it does
that and now we're off phantom power
there are Bluetooth options which you
can you know you can literally run audio
from your phone into the console you can
hear myself here real quick it's
basically how it will sound like if
you're planning to use my last review
it's crazy because you can you can do it
because it's how it sounds it's crazy
one two three one two three one two
three one two three and everything comes
out through that soundboard so it's
pretty cool next up on the console you
have the auxiliary and the output dials
so we're going to turn this to the
bottom I don't think that's much and
then go to Max like that in our top
clock position and now for the output
it's going to stop at a minimum gonna go
slow and obviously you will not hit any
enough in the minimum we're gonna go
slowly back up and go to the max it's
going to be really careful not the peak
and basically this is how it sounds like
and we're going to go back to 12 o'clock
okay so we have lowest mids and highs
we're going to be bringing this from
zero to minus 10 for the lowest first
we're going to bring it down to the
minus 10 or minus 10 right now and now
we're going to be going back to zero and
going back to plus 10 for the lows so
this is how it will sound like and now
we'll be going back to 12 o'clock now
for the mid from 0 to -10 and this is
how it will sound like a minus 10 and
we're going back to zero and now to plus
10 on the mid so this is how it will
sound like you can hear it changing
lastly with the highs 12 o'clock go to
-10 this is how it sounds like and then
zero and then two plus ten so this is
how it will sound like and I'm going to
bring everything back to 12 o'clock and
there's also the monitoring which is
mostly for me which is very helpful so
yeah I'm going to keep it at this level
I have my hotel and Paro Storm 2 which
is a guitar effects pedal it's set up
right here it is connected to a quarter
inch Jack at the back for instruments
and you know pretty much anything it's
really just a quarter inch Jack and it's
connected into there and this is
obviously connected to my guitar so this
relates to the instrument and the
instrument volume knobs down here
all right so we're going to be
controlling the volume from my effect
spell it's a lot easier
all right bringing the instrument volume
to the Max and slowly bringing up all my
Imperial
[Music]
come again
sound like
[Music]
so moving on to another fun bit of this
interface is the autotune function
which sound is you can't
you kill you can't be speaking normally
because it wouldn't really affect it
that much so you kind of need that full
set though so
okay so the thing is there are 12 keys
for this as I mentioned before and this
is pretty much how it sounds like okay
so the thing about the auto tune if you
want to turn it off just long hold on
the button and now we are back to how
the microphone sounds like moving on we
have a sound pad a b and c you can press
these and hold on to these for a
minute's worth of recording and these
little pads on here record up to 20
seconds again live never die you can
record sound bites from your phone or
through your computer even through the
3.5 Jack at the back here to connect it
to your phone
but the thing is you may not have an
adapter like at all times like I do so
I'll just be doing that for you guys
okay so yeah yeah that's coming from the
phone so let's try recording that with
this
okay before we get into that let's start
recording so hold this down it will
flash multiple times
and then wait for it to stop and then
press it again so that how you know it
will start recording
okay and now let's play back
press it again so that how you know it
will start recording
oh wait I did record I'm going to be
connecting my phone back to the
monocaster via Bluetooth
all right Bluetooth connected all right
you hear that Bluetooth is connected and
now
I'm gonna go a long hold this thing
and let me just get to one of our videos
lower light let's go inside let's find
out Xeno are you scared
let's kill this
okay and now
press record and loop deep in the
darkness we are going through it
for a whole minute with no light all
right so let's Loop that let's kill this
press record and
right
so it's looping the thing is you for
some reason you can't press it again so
that you can do that start recording
it's it's kind of weird Mauro please
look into that because I want to be
looping this and I can't Loop this so
whatever all right so uh pad volume
which is literally for this pad
[Music]
all right that is the lowest and this
the Max and now for pitch this is how it
sounds like you can change the pitch of
the microphone so going back to 12
o'clock which is a nice little nap
around here and we're going which
honestly it's pretty sick if you're
playing through screams and stuff
[Music]
okay so that's how it sounds like but I
want to see you wouldn't do it like this
so yeah you cannot Reverb and obviously
you can kill Reverb so it's not like
this so you don't really need that and
obviously that's what we put presets
which are down here we're gonna run
through them karaoke sounds like this
all right this is a place I haven't been
to in a very long time
Hull I kind of thought University
sounds like
your mom
and room okay let's just be all right
so with sidechain once you activate that
it will lower down the background music
or audio and once I stop talking it'll
bring it back up
oh let's Loop that let's kill this press
record and and now I'm back in again so
one two one two one two one two three
one two three and now I'm stopping with
low light let's go inside one two one
two one two as you can hear the
background music and audio is lowered so
the music only is a very interesting
thing it tries its best to I guess
suppress the mids of a song down or
rather the vocal layers
okay now music only
press this the vocals
all right so we're going to try it with
a different track
um something heavier okay so we're going
to start a vocal part of uh
constitutions and I Rise
go now
it really depends on the genre because
some heavier things like obviously you
know hardcore and metal colon probably
metal as well it doesn't really do a
good enough job but sometimes it does
with hardcore but also it depends on the
mixing and mastering of the track with
some of the acoustic stuff you know like
the um like 11 12s
say for a while that thing kind of works
but it really depends okay
okay um the noise as it works
low right that's how it sounds like okay
low so
in Alpha High
that's how it sounds like it cuts me off
exactly as I stop talking
like that and now with the click stuff
you better hear it
all right and now we're going to turn it
off
what do I think of the console for the
price you're getting it at and it costs
us 119 and 99 Cents or SG 165 dollars
it's a pretty good deal lacking in
certain Apartments here and there but
overall it's still one of the more
versatile Auto interfaces out there that
won't cause an arm and a leg you can
have a whole bunch of fun with the
features that are on it for streaming or
while you're gaming if you're just
opting out or you're somewhere more
intermediate and want to explore your
options you should check this out it may
look and feel cheap because the whole
thing is light and made of plastic it's
it's really light it's pretty it's
plastic but you can do so much with this
as well and with more r d I think they
give the industry a run for their money
notes on the back firstly where that
instrument Jack is right now for a
quarter inch cable there really should
have been another XLR Port similar to
Mike one's Port over here many people
out there agree with this because it
makes sense if you want to make this
console even more versatile so you can
choose to plug in another micro
instrument instead of having to scramble
you'll find a quarter inch to XLR
adapter or a XLR quarter inch adapter
and vice versa and also this 3.5
millimeter mic pod this also should have
been XLR there's also USBC ports one for
power and the other plug into your PC or
Mac it's really plug and play and if you
need to upgrade the drivers you just
need to go to their site and use their
launcher but why can't one USBC Port do
both remember they only provide you with
one usb-c cable for the console where
you need two to essentially function I
think the last thing would be that I
wish there was a way to record on the
console with a Micro SD card slot the
microphone is a solid offering the audio
interface could use small work with the
next iteration but it's a lot of fun to
play around with however if I needed to
choose between this audio interface and
the microphone Standalone the microphone
is what I'm going to go with because I
get more utility out of this and the
real question is would you get this by
bundle maybe just a podcasting console
or maybe just a mic let me know in the
comment section below and if you like
what we do maybe follow us on all of our
socials right here for more fun stuff we
put out every day also maybe hit the
like And subscribe buttons it goes a
long way if you want to see more stuff
check this out
foreign
[Music]